[Music]
game of clones how do you arrested any
kind of fluid without some sort of nose
plug sure if you're conscious you can
breathe mouth only but when you're in a
deep expositional flashbacks unconscious
sleep all nasal bets are off a few
people said hey i really like that scene
with waves and rise of skywalker then
disney said we should include some high
waves in the book of boba fett even
though it does nothing for the story but
remember berries be cray cray yo
reminding us attack of the clones exists
look i love return of the jedi as much
as the next person who was seven years
old in 1983 but even at that young of an
age i knew the three stooges-esque
offing of boba fett was idiotic so one
thing i never needed to know when they
brought him back in mandalorian was how
he got out of the sarlacc pit i don't
care how he got out of the sarlic pit i
don't want to be reminded he was ever
put in the sarlacc pit you don't have to
retcon and answer every [ __ ] question
star wars leave your stupid mistakes
alone we were all just happy boba was
back
[Laughter]
now they're literally using the patent
oswald filibuster scene from parks and
rec as a direct script for this part i
mean we literally made this joke when
boba showed up in mandalorian so we
can't quite give you a sin-off if you
let us of all people beat you to a joke
but still this is some top-notch
self-aware fan service looking directly
into the
suns this helmet removal makes the
classic star wars decompression sound
effect on release but boba jammed an
oxygen tube in there while escaping the
sarlacc so that seal's already been
broken mr sound design man even in boba
fett's current state getting bested by
jawas will always be a sin
and that little bit of floppy carrot
worm semen will be all the explanation
the show needs to get from basically
dead in the sand to able to walk for
miles behind a bantha in a driving
sandstorm scriptwriting this is starting
to feel more like dune than star wars i
hate it when people mix their dune in my
star wars what's next lady jedis episode
takes 6 minutes and 41 seconds to book
of boba fett taking robert a heinlein's
name in vain
younglings
how are they even drinking that i grow a
mustache and i have trouble getting
liquids into my mouth without making a
mess and they basically got the grill of
a 1934 brewster town car to sip through
we're almost 10 minutes in and the show
still hasn't given us a single line of
dialogue and yet the storytelling is
compelling and strong any wall-e or
anything but it's still worth it off of
the sin-off cap
tattletails alright finally some action
it's been over 10 minutes of nothing in
they're just gonna circle around each
other for a minute aren't they fun
also this stocky walkie darks on for all
the i can't see what's going on here
time boba took several shots to the face
in that last fight and unless they shot
this scene at the old beach i can't
figure out why his facial lacerations
have already healed also i know this
entire opening takes place in the
flashback to chamber and we're dealing
with memories or dreams or some [ __ ] but
the show is clearly using it as
expositional foundation so the sins all
stand plus here's a few more for
questioning me in the first place wake
up boss boba hears this no one will be
allowed to pause for a restroom break
during the boba slowly has droids help
him get his various pieces of armor in
place seen shall i kill him fennec isn't
killing me in this scene i do not taught
you cause i'm a good guy now would you
be loyal to me if i were to spare you
this is a bad idea fennec would be
fantastic at tv sins even if they do
conveniently come in handy later i'm not
enjoying soft dumb boba fred over here
wearing this much armor in the heat more
like boba sweat am i right
i'll leave quietly they're used to
seeing the huts paraded around the
streets being tasked with the job of
transporting jabba the hud around town
on a litter would you like your homeless
service and clean while you wait for
madame garcia no turning down getting
your helmet serviced what oh get your
mind out of the gutter i'm just saying
helmets get pretty icky you pervs ah
sudden flash dance if i may nope you
finnick that was a different show that
disney owns you must be thinking of
and now they throw these agents with
shields at her it's seriously like
they're taunting her with it here's 10
cents for disrespecting aos like that
where were these two chekov's deus ex
gamoran as the last few minutes
twiddling their giant green thumbs this
is by no means the worst fight scene
i've seen in a star wars property but
still results in a couple of minutes and
nothing special shooting your enemy in
the back
[Music]
alive then why the hell didn't you take
the other guy alive instead of blowing
him to pieces are those throwing stars
did this get recorded over with a 1985
canon films release i'm not even
complaining i'll take a ninja 3 the
domination right now over whatever this
running across rooftops nonsense is
[Music]
i love phoenix so much another full star
wars minute of slowly walking through
the desert if the show's gonna be 67 fat
flashbacks fine but can they be at least
a little more interesting than this
constant under the tuscan sun walking
through the desert were there no walls
to paint or floors to be waxed anywhere
how is this discount goro even seeing
through the sand to make these precision
grabs and why is tetratum sandler coming
out back first when just seconds ago we
saw all four arms reach out as if they
were face up also when did he let go of
the rodian and why none of the actual
geography or linear progression of this
moment makes any kind of sense and why
else would we love star wars other than
geography and linear progression holy
[ __ ] he just got his chest bundled so
hard he went a foot and a half into the
sand below him have you ever pounded
sand that takes so much force there's
like a whole saying in everything magic
chains magic chains auto grab anything
you throw them around this beast is kind
of fun but these are the times i wish
people like stan winston and ray
harryhausen were still around they could
have made this creature 10 times cooler
looking in their sleep
taking credit for other people's
achievements
[Music]
underpaying on your boba det
i don't like sand
it's coarse
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere
have you ever had a dream neo that you
were so sure was real
panned down from the twin sons of
tatooine uh we are now close on the
mouth of the sarlacc pit after a beat
the gloved mandalorian armor gauntlet of
boba fett grabs onto the sand outside
the sarlacc pit and the feared bounty
hunter pulls himself from the maw of the
sand beast when cameron was in egypt's
land
let my cameron
go
randy lay there like a slug it was his
only defense so you bring no tribute i
volunteer as tribute the mayor's heart
felt welcome
and regrets that he's been drawn away by
pressing matters milady what the [ __ ]
did you call me would you care to
partake in any of our sundry offerings
maybe another time
i'm here to talk business i didn't know
you were such a ballet fan i thought you
just liked it in private
your helmet is so big
what do you want me to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Laughter]